all
right boys vent frustration over
products for menstruation so should we
demand an apology from boys who know
basic biology Connecticut teenage boys
aren't they all RI down a tampon
dispenser just 20 minutes after it was
installed in their High School
bathroom which raises the question why
did it take so
long the boys tampon vending machine and
let's pause to appreciate the beauty of
that wording was installed as part of a
new state law that calls for free
menstrual products in at least one men's
bathroom in every High School yeah it's
it's a law that is about as logical as
free Aqua Velva in a girl's
bathroom in an email obtained by a
Connecticut newssite the principal
expressed his deep disappointment quote
I am aware that the law says men's
bathroom but the actions today were the
work of immature boys not men this is
the most egregious instance of vandalism
It generally only happens in boys
bathrooms you think that's rich this is
the most egregious instance of vandalism
no it's the most heroic fact is they are
boys and the only thing that upsets a
woke leming more is someone who's
resistant to their brainwash and
adolescent boys are the least
susceptible to woke so it's not
immaturity it's Common Sense
also
also saying that these boys are not men
while pretending that girls are boys I
think you've lost all credibility on
this topic you're not a man you're a
mouse and a balless one at that now
apparently the schools had other
vandalism incidents including broken
stall doors torn down soap dispensers
and things stuffed in toilets and now an
egregiously harmed men's tampon
dispenser well what the hell do you
expect you put a tampon dispenser in a
teenage boy's bathroom and you think
it's going to make it through the end of
the school year you should be grateful
it lasted one day but Mr principal maybe
you shouldn't blame those boys for
acting up perhaps it was just their time
of the
[Laughter]
month
Iris how would you feel if there were a
tampon machine in your son's school
restroom and he t
down I would be so
disappointed that he didn't call
me do it together son yeah that's a
bonding yeah I
just this is the world we live in I mean
obviously the first thing you want to
say to the principal is shut up Gavin
um totally the
laws it it goes let's say this isn't
need I would think it would be a case by
case situation unless maybe the numbers
are off but the population of trans boys
using the bathrooms in elementary school
is what and that's what I would ask like
is it three times a day is it once a
year is it one student every semester
that fits this description so why even
put them in that situation MH because
they still have the nurse's office yeah
and if they're I'm assuming if they're
trying to live their life as a Young Man
the last thing they want is to be in the
men's room with other men looking for
hey fellas any one of you grab the
tampons I need one like that's a good
point
toally yeah Tyrus quit put them in your
nose bro it's not funny like oh you put
in them you get super
absorbent you didn't play with your
mom's tampons like these things what is
this I was like this is amazing and one
time I got a bloody nose and my mother
went in her purse and was like hold
still and not a drop on my shirt the
things are phenomenal and as and bullet
wounds and as a father now like I got
three daughters so I'm all about the
being ready for the pads or tampons or
whatever we're doing like I got a set
for each one I'm ready to go I'm in
there you don't got to talk to your mom
I got you I carry one in my bag so if I
die in a car accident and you guys see a
bunch of tampons in my bag just to let
you know I'm an active father with
daughters I was not
transitioning
cat as someone who's often mistaken for
a teenage
boy no he's
right she's right she puts on a hat you
know yeah you really can't you really
have no
idea um is what do you expect from a
teenage they destroy
everything okay well but also as someone
who used to clean bathrooms
professionally mhm yeah at Boston Market
it's like it's not the fault of whoever
ended up having to clean up this mess
which kind of sucks for the janitor
that's like what' you do today like I'm
cleaning up the busted open tampon
dispenser in the boy's bathroom like
that sucks as a day but as as you know
in high school like I provided my own
tampons yeah I just I don't know I feel
like like Tyra said how many people does
this really impact and it's small school
in Connecticut and now it's national
news and uh I just don't have much more
to say about oh
Emily um yeah they tore it down in 20
minutes I think that's restraint I know
right took you long enough um okay so
here's the thing though it's it's
national news because it was state law
that mandates that tampons have to be in
boys bathrooms as well as wom and to
your point I love that point because the
the statistics think about where your
tax dollars are being mandated where you
are being forced to allocate mhm the
amount the expense that is for how many
and then when you weigh so this
principal talked about vulgar vandalism
he said he was disgusted right you know
it's
impolite well I would argue that worse
than vandalism or being a a a boy not a
man is the rape that occurred in the
Virginia women's bathroom by a man
wearing a skirt a boy wearing a skirt
and her family is suing their school
district for 30 million because they
condoned it because it because laws like
this are what open the field for
everyone to take advantage of it so I
would rather air on the side of one
person being like I have to walk to the
nurse's office and having one person be
raped in the bathroom because someone
else worse yeah and if you if you're if
you're transitioning I think you can
also carry a tampon with you not that I
would know Vince I carry them for my
daughters all the time not a big deal
yeah point of Pride Vince did they do
the right thing or was it immature look
if you walk into a boy's bathroom and
the worst thing you see is a dispenser
on on the ground you're already winning
okay yes as guys we've walked into
bathrooms and it looks like there was a
pagan sacrifice in the Stalls and you're
just like I just want to know what I can
touch and not touch you know the I think
the problem here and Emily hit on it is
when you try to legislate this stuff I I
mean I grew up different sometimes you
have to trust people and when I grew up
in the 80s from middle school high
school and beginning of college you know
we didn't have to be legislated and what
to accept not accept and 80s was
androgynous as hell between Boy George
the bands where the guys were getting
girls had long hair we wearing makeup
none of us asked questions we accepted
everything and girls were into George
Michael and we like surprise he likes me
more
um so but you didn't have to legislate
and if someone did attack someone who
was transer gay or whatever it was the
the toxic males that would defend them
so the problem is don't try to legislate
this stuff you know just sometimes you
just have to let things happen and let
people gravitate to where they're going
to go to and you know what kids will
work this out you know I I think people
should just follow my lead I don't think
I ever actually used the restroom in
high school I got my business done
before and after I was never going to
sit on that toilet not for anything it
was an all gu school so there wasn't
even yeah it was pretty bad I don't want
to talk about it wait I'm on TV I have
to all right coming up lib start to anic
if you destroy a statue that's
satanic hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else